où gilles casanova merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france vous êtes ancien
conseiller du ministère de l'intérieur
et consultant en stratégie et
communication
on avait déjà un peu les grandes lignes
de cette allocution qu'on avez-vous
pensé viens nous avons noté déjà huit
minutes de moins que la dernière fois
c'est un progrès la théâtralisation est
toujours là et le fond est toujours un
peu pour c'est à dire on a beaucoup de
grands moments beaucoup de grandes idées
comme souvent mais à un moment quand il
faut concrétiser
on se rend compte qu'on revient à du
classique c'est-à-dire tout ce que j'ai
fait depuis trois ans c'était bien je
vais continuer et on comprend pourquoi
69 % des français interrogés pensent
qu'il ne modifiera en rien sa stratégie
ou son rapport à la politique ou
français les français et la classe
politique attendait des actes concrets
ce qu'on sait en tout cas c'est qu'à
partir de demain il n'y aura plus de
zone orange en métropole tout où va
passer au vert les restaurants vont
pouvoir rouvrir les écoles elles vont
pouvoir accueillir les élèves à partir
du 22 juin
voilà pour les choses concrètes
finalement ce ses grandes idées
présentées par le chef de l'état il a
pris soin de n'oublier personne
alors d'abord la grande idée on sait que
dans les études faites par les mêmes
instituts dans l'ensemble de l'occident
le gouvernement et les autorités
françaises sont celles qui ont le plus
mauvais résultat auprès de leur
population
quant à la capacité qu elles ont eu à
faire face à la crise du coronavirus
donc il sait cela évidemment
et donc il a d'abord adressé un énorme
satisfecit aux français qu'il a
poursuivie par un énorme satisfecit au
gouvernement qui s'est conclue par un
plus énorme encore satisfecit à lui-même
restant là dans son habituel stratégie
de communication
comtois résumer à la phrase qu'il a eue
dans la fin de son intervention et moi
le tout premier qu'il en fait tu aurais
pu lire à peu près à chaque paragraphe
de ce qu'il a dit ça c'est le premier
aspect c'est à dire finalement vous avez
été tellement bien que en y
réfléchissant bien nous aussi au
gouvernement et moi-même à la présidence
nous avons été bien ensuite il a dit
l'indépendance ans mais il n'a pas donné
la moindre piste à cette indépendance
il a donné comme élément cette
indépendance la grande opération
proposée à l'union européenne avec
madame merkel qui consiste à emprunter
sur les marchés financiers
ce n'est pas la banque centrale
européenne qui va financer ce sont les
marchés financiers c'est à dire que on
va se mettre sur la tête une énorme
pression et dans un dispositif très
particulier puisque chaque fois que la
france touchera 30 milliards qu elle
garantir à 100 milliards
donc la pression sur la france dans ce
dispositif sera extrêmement forte dont
ils parlent d'indépendance il a même eu
le mont souveraineté mais on voit mal où
est la souveraineté
avec une telle pression il a parlé de
l'europe il a parlé aussi de de se
reconstruire de reconstruire le monde de
demain avec des grandes idées je dois me
l'appliqué à moi même at il dit
également c'est une humilité qu'on lui
connaît peu finalement il se remet en
question le chef de l'état vous
n'écoutez pas certaines chaînes
d'information qui le trouvent humble
tellement humble toujours plus humbles à
chacune de ses interventions
c'est un festival d'humilité ou du moins
il est présenté comme tel il est pas
plus humble que d'habitude
il est moi le tout premier c'est sa
stratégie
c'est comme ça qu'il n'a emporté en
étant au départ une personnalité peu
connue des français pensent et printemps
ça voulait dire penser à moi
il a gagné la bataille présidentielle
autour de l'idée de penser printemps
quelques autres affaires que vous avez
noté ont un peu perturbé la campagne
mais le fond c'est que c'est lui le
projet puisque il a rassemblé des gens
qui ne pensent pas la même chose qui
viennent de droite qui viennent de
gauche qui pour ces élections
municipales ont refait des accords avec
la droite
ondres fait d accord avec la gauche dans
un désordre indescriptible
donc le programme c'est sa personne donc
son humilité est une humilité
théâtralisée car il n'a pas le choix il
n'y a pas d'autres orientations que le
suivre sa personne c'est aussi un
message au premier ministre dont il voit
difficilement comment il peut se
débarrasser
il a bien engagé beaucoup de
consultations mais pour l'instant ça
n'aboutit pas à trouver la réponse à
cette question il est dans la même
position nicolas sarkozy il y a dix ans
qui voulait se défaire de françois
fillon et qui finalement a été conduit à
le garder après six mois d'annonce que
on allait voir ce qu'on allait voir
alors on va écouter justement emmanuel
macron ce soir justement sur le bilan
qu'il tire de cette crise sanitaire
écouter premier bilan
bien sûr cette épreuve a aussi révélé
des failles des fragilités notre
dépendance à d'autres continents pour
nous procurer certains produits non
lourdeur d'organisation nos inégalités
sociales et territoriales
je veux que nous tirions toutes les
leçons de ce que nous avons vécu est
avec vous comprendre ce que nous avons
mieux réussi au moins bien réussi que
nos voisins nos forces nous les
confronterons nos faiblesses nous les
corrigerons vite et fort
voilà pour le bilan tiré c'est une
première victoire il s'est félicité de
cette victoire sur cette première étape
de de la crise sanitaire
pas de mot en tout cas sur est on prêt
pour une prochaine
épidémie si tant est qu'elles qu'elles
arrivent à l'automne chacun sait que
nous n'y sommes pas plus près que
précédemment sismique nous avons
maintenant une surabondance de masques
et une surproduction puisque les
autorités ont demandé dans le désordre à
toute sorte d'acteur de fabriquer des
masques et que maintenant nous avons un
nombre de masques qui dépasse largement
ce que nous sommes capables de consommer
mais vous noterez par exemple qu'il
parle de l'aide apportée aux à la
filière automobile qui a été de
plusieurs milliards donc elle est
importante et il y dit avec des mots
toujours sur un style très théâtral que
ça ça va aux entreprises et aux
travailleurs mais il n'a pas s'il y est
quand le groupe ps a annoncé qu'il
remplacerait 400 intérimaires français
par 400 polonais qui viennent sur la
base de la circulaire bolkenstein et ça
c'est tout de même une drôle de façon de
faire l'indépendance et la souveraineté
alors il dit aussi que pour redresser
l'économie de ce pays et essayer de
combler ses 500 milliards d'euros qui
ont été débloqués par l'état
il n'y aura pas de hausse d'impôts pour
les français c'est une c'est une bonne
nouvelle j'imagine où on va là commenté
avec vous j'ai le casanova
il a beaucoup associé aussi la volonté
d'allier l'écologie à à l'économie
s'était attendu ça aussi oui c'est le
grand discours de l'epo logique qui est
un discours obligé on lit dans les
gazettes qu'ils seront tous les week end
à la lanterne à versailles
ses prédécesseurs s'y rendaient en
voiture avec des motards qu'ils aient
fait beaucoup de pollution lui cire en
hélicoptère
est ce aussi écologistes que ça alors on
va écouter à présent l'association human
rights watch qui a qui a alerté le chef
de l'état en tous cas sur les abus des
forces de l'ordre qui abuseraient en
tout cas des contrôles au faciès écouter
ce qu'il demandait et on va analyser ce
qu'a répondu
emmanuel macron en français emmanuel
macron devrait indiquer la mise en place
de réformes concrètes pour mettre fin au
racisme au sein des forces de l'ordre
ces réformes devraient inclure la fin
des contrôles d'identité abusifs et
discriminatoire au coeur des
préoccupations concernant le racisme
institutionnel et la discrimination dans
le pays
gilles casanova vous l'avez entendu le
chef de l'état a abordé ce sujet plutôt
sensible on sait qu'il a du mal à à en
parler en tout cas il a parlé de
retrouver l'unité du pays il a condamné
le racisme et dans le même temps il a
dit que l'ordre républicain ne pouvait
être assurée comme par les policiers
qu'il a salués il a bien fait écoutez il
a réaffirmé la république française face
à des gens qui proposent un dispositif
j'ai totalitaires dans lequel on va
réécrire l'histoire
déboulonner les statues condamner les
blancs parce que finalement on revient
dans un dispositif dans lesquels il y à
une race inférieure ce sont les blancs
voilà le dispositif
or on sait très bien dans les deux
dernières années que s'il y a eu des
violences policières c'est
essentiellement contre les filets jaunes
et pas pour des raisons raciales mais
pour des raisons politiques et que ce
n'est pas personnellement les policiers
qui ont décidé de violence contre les
gilets jaunes mais que c'était une
décision de l'exécutif
on se souvient de ses engagements ou
policiers à aller au contact directement
à s'affronter à ces manifestations ce
qu'ils ont fait d'ailleurs en ayant
eux-mêmes de nombreux blessés
donc on n'est pas du tout en phase d'une
police raciste qui ferait des contrôles
au faciès tout le temps on regarde la
réalité on se rend compte que la drogue
et la délinquance s'épanouissent dans
des quartiers de relégation dans lequel
on a relégué des gens qui sont arrivés
sur notre territoire plus tardivement et
qui sont d'une origine étrangère c'est
la réalité
alors évidemment ils sont souvent ou
parfois d'une couleur de peau légèrement
différente mais ça n'est pas le
blême de leur couleur de peau c'est le
problème d'avoir construit des zones de
relégation dans lequel s'épanouissent
les trafics et la délinquance c'est ça
le problème
alors si on dit maintenant quand vous
êtes noir ou quand vous êtes d'une
minorité visible vous avez le droit à
tous les trafics
évidemment ça n'est pas possible et il
est logique qu'un président de la
république française le réaffirme il ne
pouvait pas ne pas le faire et c'est
toujours la politique du dut en même
temps il ne contente un petit peu tout
le monde finalement dans son discours
moi le premier
comme il le dit je comprends les uns je
comprends les autres en même temps c'est
le fond de son programme
depuis trois ans il n'y a pas renoncé il
indique que c'est à partir de ce
programme qu'il va bâtir son avenir
du moins l'avenir du pays et son avenir
lui même puisque on voit qu'il vise la
présidentielle prochaine
et donc il est là contraint par ce qu'il
a lui même construit et qu'ils ont fait
ou d'un certain point de vue une
nouvelle méthode justement est ce que le
président a tiré des leçons est ce qu'il
y aura une nouvelle méthode selon vous
c'est ce que les français attendent il
dit quelque chose qui change c'est
jusqu'ici ils voulaient détruire les
corps intermédiaires organiser une
verticalité absolue entre lui et les
français jupiter et ceux qui ne sont
bien là ils pensent que c'est finalement
très risquées et que le résultat n'a pas
jusqu'ici était la hauteur de ses
espoirs dont il veut entraîner avec lui
tous les acteurs intermédiaires des
collectivités territoriales les maires
les présidents de conseils
départementaux régionaux les
intercommunalités tout ce qui existe il
veut les entraîner derrière lui en lui
redonnant
responsabilité des libertés la
difficulté c'est qu'il a pris soin dans
les trois années précédentes de leur
retirer tout leur financement
c'est ce que réclame d'ailleurs les
communes et des territoires davantage de
liberté apparemment le message a été
entendu
la liberté oui mais il n'y a pas
l'argent qui va avec
c'est une difficulté à laquelle il va se
heurter d'autant que l'argent il y en a
beaucoup qui a été débloqué dans
l'urgence mais il n'est pas absolument
certain qu'il soit prêt à revenir sur
tous les dispositifs qui l'a mis en
place et qui ont dévitalisées les
capacités des collectivités
territoriales pour faire face à nos
responsabilités
achille casanova une dernière question
pour vous emmanuel macron doit reprendre
la parole nadège abderrazak le disais en
juillet prochain ça sera pour une des
soeurs et une dissolution un remaniement
écoutez d'abord on doit noter que ce
qu'il a fait était sur la forme très
léchée très beau s'étaient enregistrés
et et déjà il y a un vrai souci du du
design de l'image on voit bien qu'il
n'ya pas encore de programme
il n'y a pas encore de décision il n'y a
pas encore de stratégie
il annonce donc qu'il donnera ses
conclusions en juillet il ne donne pas
de date précise
il indique qu'il a consultés qu'il va
consulter
c'est un petit peu la prophétie auto
réalisatrice
c'est à dire qu'il espère qu à force
d'annoncer qu'il consulte partout et
tout le monde tout le monde à venir vers
lui en essayant de lui proposer ses
services
car pour l'instant et il ne trouve pas
beaucoup de personnalités qu'ils soient
prêts à monter sur son char ou champions
gr de suivre le regard que l'on porte
merci beaucoup gilles casanova d'avoir
été en direct sur astel france pour
analyser cette allocution du président
de la république